Okay, let's get
these cameras set.
Perfect.
Everything's recorded,
nobody can betray me.
And there's absolutely nothing
that can go wrong,
that's for sure.
‘Cause it's all on tape, right?
That's right, Donald.
Hey buddy!
When you watch this tape,
remember that you set these
cameras up and don't get scared.
Hi, uh, this is Elizabeth Warren
and I need two pizzas.
And I want it sent
to my home address,
which is 222 Cherokee Drive,
Pocahontas, Massachusetts.
(sounding out)
Anominous?
(organ playing)
I don't see what the big deal
is,
kids love being separated
from their families.
It's like camp.
(sounding out)
Omininous?
(organ playing)
(rock music)
(knocking)
Come on, Mike!
I'm trying, sir! I don't-
(knocking harder)
Shred it all, shred it all!
I'm trying! You can only
do one at a time!
Why did we write all this stuff
down in the first place?!
I don't remem-
(sounding out)
Amuminous?
...frustrate parts of his agenda
and his worst inclinations.
I should know,
I am one of them-
Mike, what the hell are you
doing at my desk?
Oh sir!
I was writing your memoirs,
because you didn't wanna do it.
Oh, that's great.
I love memoirs.
Sure, sure.
They're the things in your head
that you cry about!
And then put on paper.
Make sure you include
that I killed Osama bin Laden,
Uh huh.
and that I passed
the healthcare bill,
Yes.
and that I was the first
black president.
Comin' right up sir.